[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع واحداث وتتفاعل طبعا البدايه
بالبونديال وهو الذي يشغل العالم جميعا
هذه اللقطات من ستاد لوسين في قطر الذي
يشهدوا مباراه البرازيل والكاميرون قبل
العبور الى دور السته عشر
اما هذه الصور فتاتينا من البرازيل لعشاق
كره القدم وهم يتابعون اداء منتخبهم في
خطر الصور طبعا من مدينه سوف اقوله
وفي المواجهه الثانيه في استاد تسعه سبعه
اربعه في الدوحه بين صربيا وسويسرا
ومنافسه حاسمه للصعود
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في مشهد قتل التقطته الكاميرات مقاطع تظهر
ما بدا اعداما ميدانيا للشاب فلسطيني
جنوبيا نابلس برصاص ضابط اسرائيلي من
المسافه صفر ورئاسه الفلسطينيه تطالب
بحمايه دوليه مما وصفته بجرائم منهجه
للحكومات الاسرائيليه والاتحاد الاوروبي
يقول ان التصاعد العنف الاسرائيلي في
الضفه الغربيه والقدس المحتله يثير قلقا
متزايده
روسيا والغرب ومسارته دبلوماسيه متعثره
شويبس وفي اتصال
بها هو مفتاح الحل وفي مسعد اردوغان يدعو
لبناء سريعا لارضيه التفاوض وبعد يومين من
الاجتماعات وبغياب الروسيه منظمه الامن
والتعاون تخفق في تبني موقف موحد من الحرب
انقره طالب حلفائها بقطع الدعم عن قوات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه وتؤكد عزمها المضيئه
بالعمليه العسكريه وبعد اعلانها تقليص
دورياتها في الشمال السوري واشنطن تعرب عن
قلقها من عرقله العمليات ضد تنظيم الدوله
وما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه تعلق
تعاونها مع التحالف الدولي
في افغانستان بعد هجوم استهدف مقر السفاره
الباكستانيه وسط العاصمه الامن الافغاني
يشتبك مع مسلحين قرب المبنى الحكومه تؤكد
انها لم تسمح بالمساس بامن البعثات
الدبلوماسيه واسمى بلد تعتبر الهجوم
محاوله اغتيال لرئيس بعثتها وتطالب بتحقيق
الفوري
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصه
الرقميه كنا نقشنا معكم الاستعدادات
الجاريه لتشكيل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده هذه الحكومه التي توصف بالاكثر
يمينيه في تاريخ الصراع ملامح التشكيله
التي بدات تتضح لم تخالف التوقعات في ما
يتعلق ببعض الاسماء على راسها تمار بن
جرير فيما بدات اصواتهم في الولايات
المتحده تطالب رئيس جبيل بالتعامل بحزم مع
التداعيات المحتمله لمثل هذه التشكيله
الوزاريه لاستطلاع يا رايكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم قبل قليل
السؤال التالي هل سيؤدي الجدل بشان
التشكيل المحتمله لحكومه الى تغييرها جاءت
النتيجه التصويت كما يلي نحو واحدا 51%
قالوا لا
سيتم تشكيلها وفق التوقعات الحين صوت نحو
ثلاثه وعشرين بنعم معتبرين انه سيتم تراجع
فعلا اخيرا قال نحن 26 بالمئه انه سيؤدي
فقط هذا الجدل الى تغيير طفيف للحفاظ على
التحالف السياسي القائم في اسرائيل هذا
السؤال سيبقى مطروحا كالعاده على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
لقاء هنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
و نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا
في الساعه 12 و 5 دقائق بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه تتابعون معنا الجوله الرياضيه
اليوميه يوميات المونديال التي ترصد
بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم قطر
2002 2022
[موسيقى]
نبدا من الاراضي الفلسطينيه ومن مشهد
صادما والثقته الكاميرات لعمليه قتل شاب
فلسطيني برصاصه قوات الاحتلال وقد اثارت
عمليه القتل هذه موجه من الغضب فقد نشر
ناشطونه صورا تظهر فلسطينيين
حاول تخليص الشاب من قبضه الجندي الذي
اطبق الخناقه عليه ثم سحبه الى مكان اخر
واطلق النار عليه وقال جهود عيان ان قوه
الاحتلال منع التوام الاسعاف من الوصول
الى الشاب بعد اصابته وزعمت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان هذا الشاب حاول سرقه سلاح
الجندي وطعنه يقوم الجندي بعد ذلك باطلاق
النار عليه
وقد قالت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه ان اعدام
الشاب عمار حمدي مفلح بدم بارد برصاص
الاحتلال في بلده حوارا جنوب نابلس يعد
جريمه بشعه ضمن سلسله من الجرائم التي
ترتكب يوميا بحق ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
واضافه رئاسه الفلسطينيه في بيان لها ان
هذه الجرائم التي اصبحت سياسه رسميه
للحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه تستوجب
التدخل العاجله لتوفير الحمايه الدوليه
للفلسطينيين
فيما اعرب الاتحاد الاوروبي عن بالغ قلقه
مما وصفه بتصاعد العنف الاسرائيلي في
الضفه الغربيه بما فيها القدس المحتله
واكد الاتحاد في بيان مقتضب ان قتل
الاحتلال لعشره فلسطينيين خلال اثنتين 72
ساعه فقط انما يعكس استخدام قوى الامن
الاسرائيليه للقوه المميته وهو ما يخالف
مبادئ القانون الدولي وفقا ما جاء في
البيان الذي اضاف ان الاتحاد العام الحالي
هو الاكثر دمويه منذ عام 2006 وطالب
بالتحقيق في وقوع الضحايا بين المدنيين
وضمان المسائله
معنى من غزه الدكتور صالح النعامي الباحث
المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
هي قضيه المساءله تحديدا هي التي تطرح
باستمرار متى يمكن ان نشهد فعل المساءله
عن هذه الاعمال
تاريخ الصراع يدلل بشكل لا يقبل التاويل
انه اذا كان الرهان على
رد ما يعرف بالمجتمع الدولي وتحديد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واوروبا
فاعتقد ان هناك
واضحه وصارخه همم اسرائيل تقدم على هذه
الجرائم لانها تدرك سلفا بانها همم لن
تسال يعني في النهايه حتى عندما يتم طرح
السلوك الاجرامي الصهيوني امام المحافل
الدوليه هناك من هو مستعد لاستخدام حق
الفيتو طبعا اقصد بتحديد من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه همم طبعا هذا بشكل
يتناقض مع سلوك هذا هذا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واوروبا مع ما يحدث الان في في
اوكرانيا على سبيل المثال هناك تعتبر
جرائم جرائم حرب بينما هنا همم نجد انه
العالم اما ان يصمت او ينجد يعني يد قريبك
كلاميه او انه يتواطئ كما تفعل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان
هناك ثمه يعني تغيير يمكن الرهان عليه في
هذا الجانب
موقف همم الاتحاد الاوروبي الا يعتبر نوعا
ما متقدما ولو قليلا عن البيانات العاديه
يعني هو نظريه يعتبر موقفا متقدما ولكن
مثل هذه البيانات التي تقدير يعني سبقا اا
اصدر الاتحاد الاوروبي مثل هذه البيانات
ولكن الان التحدي كيف بالامكان ان تتحول
هذه البيانات الى سلوك سياسي او سلوك عملي
يمكن ان يقنع اسرائيل بيتوقف عن هذا
السلوكيه ما نحن لا نعرفك ان انت تتشكل
الحكومه كما وصفت في في المقدم استاذ محمد
بانها الاكثر يمنيه والاكثر تطرفا في
تاريخ الكيان الصهيوني فاذا كان هناك الان
ان وزير امن وطني بين مؤتمر بالانجليزي
يقول بانه حريه مطلقه
لحرس الحدود والشرطه ان يطلق النار كما
يشاؤون ثم يمنحه من الحصانه عندما يشارك
في الحكومه القادمه
اشخاص من الذين يعني ساهم في تشكيلته مثل
مثل الذي سيكون وزير للماليه وهو احد
مؤسسي تنظيم فتيه التلال الارهابي ثمار
بني كبير شخصيا كان ينتمي الى تنظيم حركه
داخل الارهابي ووجه ضده 53 لائحه اتهام
بممارسه العنف ضد الفلسطينيين او التحريض
على العنف فاعتقد انه اذا كان هذا لم هذا
هذه التشكيله مع كل ما تطرحه لا تحرك ساكن
امام
المجتمع عندما يعتقد ان هذا ايضا تشجيع
يعني لمرحله اكثر خطوره في الاجرام
الصهيوني ضد الشعب الفلسطيني مطلب الحمايه
الدوليه دائما تكرره القياده الفلسطينيه
كيف يمكن ان تكون هناك خطوه اولى في هذا
الاتجاه
يعني هذا في تقدير هذا يفترض لو كان
الامور يعني تحكم بالعدل ومنطق هذا كان
يعني الحمايه الدوليه هذا ما يفرضوا
المواقع الاحتلال هناك شعب اعزل يتعرض كما
شاهدتم اليوم بعمليه اعدام ميداني قدام
بارد بمناسبه حدث لانه هناك من كان من كان
قد وفق هذا الامر همم بشكل مباشر ولكن مثل
هذه التحدث في يوميا في الساحه الفلسطينيه
لكن للاسف الشديد الاصل ان تبدا القياده
قياده السلطه بهذا الامر لا يعقل انه
السلطه الفلسطينيه تصدر بيانات الرئاسه
السلطه الزر بيانات الطالب بالتحقيق وتبرر
بحمايه بحمايه الشعب الفلسطيني في الوقت
الذي لاسف الشديد التواصل نمط علاقتها مع
الكيان الصهيوني القائم على التعاون
الامنيه
الدكتور نعامي الى توجه الى محكمه
الدوليه يعني في بالتوازي مع ذلك
لا لكن هذا هناك رسائل عندما تواصل عندما
يتم همم تواصل التعاون الامني مع الاحتلال
فانت تعطي رساله يعني بعدم جديه هذه
التحركات لا يمكن يعني لا يمكن انه ثناء
في الوقت ان تنجد بالسلوك الاحتلال وفي
نفس الوقت وتطالب المجتمع الدولي بتوفير
حمايه في الوقت الذي انت كطرف فلسطيني
رسمي ان تواصل نمط العلاقه مع هذا الكيان
وكان شيء لم يكن لا يقبل ان ان ان ان ترسم
السلطه في توفير الامن للمستوطنين ولا ولا
الجنود الذين يقتلون ابناء الشعب
الفلسطيني ثم اذا عندما يترتكم الجرائم
نقول تعالوا يعني دعونا ان همم ساعدونا في
منح حمايه دوليه يتوجب ان تكون هناك
للسلطه موقف واضح وصار رمسيه من هناك
قرارات المجلس الوطني والمجلس المركزي
التي تطالب بشكل واضح وصريح يعني وقف
التعاون الامني ووقف نمط العلاقه القائم
الان ما بين السلطه واسرائيل لكن للاسف
اكيد مثل هذه السلوك يشجع الكيان الصهيوني
على هذه الممارسات ويعني وهذا يعني نعم
شكرا لك يا دكتور صالح النا عمي من غزه
شكرا جزيلا
وفي ردود فعل الفصائل الفلسطينيه قالت
حركه حماس ان اعدام شاب بدم بارد في حواره
جنوبيه نابلس تعكس السلوك العدوانيه
والفاشيه للاحتلال وجيشه وان مشهد جريمه
الاعدام سيرتد على الاحتلال وسيدفع ثمنها
من جانبها قالت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي ان
عمليه الاعدام على مرئا وما اسمع من
العالم
وجريمه حرب مكتمله الاركان في وقت اعتبرت
فيه الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين جريمه
اعدام الشاب عمار مفلح شاهدا جديدا على
فاشيه واجرام الاحتلال وارهابه المنظم ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني
هذا المشهد التصاعدي يعيد الى الواجهه
التوجس السائده على ساحه الفلسطينيه من
تصاعد الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه خاصه مع
قدوم حكومه توصف بالاكثر تشددا حيث يواصل
بني منه المكلف بتشكيل هذه الحكومه
الجديده مسائيه للتوصل الى اتفاق مع باقي
شركائه في الاحزاب الدينيه المتشدده من
اجل تشكيل هذه الحكم
بالتوقيع على الاتفاق الائتلافيه مع بيكسل
اسمه زعيم الصهيونيه الدينيه يكون
ازال اكثر شركائه تعنتا واشدهم تطرفا من
طريقه نحو ارضي حكومته السادسه على
الكنيست لنيل الثقه قريبا اسمه يتولى
حقيبه الملك
وسيستحوذ حزمه على الاداره المدنيه التي
تتحكم بكل مفاصل حياه الفلسطيني حيث يسعى
الى الغاء دورها ودمج خدماتها في اطار
الوزارات الحكوميه وهو ما يشكل براي
كثيرين خطوه متقدمه نحوه تنفيذ الضم
الهادي للضفه الغربيه
الضم التدريجي
وايضا التطير العرقي في القدس وفرض
التقسيم الزماني والمكاني على المسجد
الاقصى هذا هو عنوان وجدول اعمال هذه
الحكومه اليمنيه المتطرفه في اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
بصفته وزيرا للامن القومي كما سيتولى
الاشراف على سرايا حرس الحدود ضد الضفه
الغربيه المحتل
الفلسطيني
الجيش
في وزاره الامن الداخلي
تعيينه عربيلتيطان في مواقع مؤثره سيمنحهم
القدره على فرض اجنداتهم المتطرفه اذ يسعى
هؤلاء الى اطفاء الشرعيه القانونيه على 65
بؤره استيطانيه عشوائيه اقامها مستوطنون
مسلحون دون اذن حكومي على اراضي
الفلسطينيين الخاصه وهدم منازلهم واجلاء
عشرات التجمعات الفلسطينيه في المناطق
المصنفه
في طريقه لتشكيل حكومته السادسه ايضا
حكومه يمنيه دينيه اصليه خالص
يقولوا خصومه السياسيون انها لا تنظر
بتصيد خطير في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
فحسب بل ستقود حتما الى صدام مع المجتمع
الدولي ومع الاداره الامريكيه على وجه
الخصوص الجزيره جنوب القدس المحتله
[موسيقى]
الحلو دبلوماسيه والمشروط لسحب روسيا
قواتها من اوكرانيا لانهاء الحرب مرفوض
النظر انتهى الاتصال الهاتفي بين المستشار
الالمانيه والرئيس الروسي بوتين الذي اكد
لشوز استمرار استهداف البنا التحتيه في
اوكرانيا لمواجهه الهجمات
المتحدث باسم الكربلائي الروسي الشروط
التي تحدث عنها الرئيس الامريكي مقابل
التفاوض معه هذه الشروط عاد البيت الابيض
اليوم لتاكدها بالقول انها مسار
الدبلوماسيه الوحيد الممكن
واشنطن وبرلين ومن معهما لا مفاوضات بشرط
سحب القوات الروسيه من اوكرانيا ولا تراجع
عن التكتيك العسكريه الحالي في الحرب ساعه
من الارض والرد عبر الهاتف بين الرئيس
بوتين والمستشار الالماني
على خلاف بشان جوهر القضايا المطروحات جاء
في بيان الكريم
الاوكرانيه من التدابير التي لمفر منها
لمواجهه الهجمات الاستفزازيه
تحدث عن حسن مستشار الرئيس الروسي على
التوصل باسرع وقت ممكن الى حل دبلوماسي
يتضمن انسحاب القوات الروسيه كما ابلغه
المانيا القصف الروسي للمنشات المدنيه
الاوكرانيه سبق المكالمه لم تغير شيئا في
خريطه المواقف رد على العرض المقدم من
الرئيس الامريكي صرح المتحدث باسم الكريم
لنبايدا قال عمليا ان المفاوضات لن تكون
ممكنه الا بعد ان يخرج بوتن من اوكرانيا
وهو مطر فضه موسك بوضوح على حد تعبيره
واكد استمرار العمليه العسكريه كان الرئيس
الامريكي وبحضور نظيره الفرنسي عبر عن
استعداده التحدث مع بوتن اذا سحب قوته من
اوكرانيا واظهر نيه لانهاء الحرب في ظل كل
هذه التطورات هل اصبحت امكانيه الحل
الديبلوماسي بعيده اكثر فاكثر لا تغلق
موسكوا الباب نهائيا ولكنها لا تقبل
المطالب الغربيه لفتح قنوات اتصال جديه
تضع حدا للحرب المدمر للجميع ولا قرارات
في ختام اجتماع منظمه الامن والتعاون في
اوروبا الذي قيد في بولندا عدم السماح
لوزير الخارجيه روسيا بالحضور اشعل حرب
تصريحات اتهم لابروف الولايات المتحده
وحلف الاطلس بمحاولتي تقويدي عمل اي هيئه
اقليميه فاتف الى تعزيز الحوار مثل منظمه
الامن والتعاون في اوروبا رابطه دول جنوب
شرق اسيا وقال ان الحديث عن اهتمام الغرب
بالتوصلي الى نوع من التسويه السلميه لا
يسيروا اهتمام روسيا التصعيد المزدوج
دبلوماسيه وعسكري في الحرب الى متى من
سيناريو سيئون الى اسوء تمضي شهور صراع
تداعياته المؤلمه ابعده من اوكرانيا بكثير
معنى من برلين
استاذ العلوم السياسيه بجامعه ستانفورد في
برلين ومن موسكو ديمتري بابتش وهو محلل
سياسي روسي اهلا بضيفين نبدا من برلين
والسيد بروكلين هل كان يطمع المستشار شوز
اكثر مما سمعه من بوتن
لا لا
توقعاته ولكن الصوره الاكبر
الصين
تخفيف وتصعيد ورايين عودته همم اتصالات
هاتفيه
ولقاء الرئيس بادل مع ايمانويل
وكله ذلك ااه يضعوا
الدبلوماسيه والجميع يقول انه ليس هناك
حلل
عسكريه
وينبغي ان تبدا الجهود الدبلوماسيه
والمحادثات للحديث عن وقفه اطلاق النار او
للتواصل الى نتيجه النهائيه ولكن كل هذا
سيد بابيت في موسكو لا يبدو ان الرئيس
بوتن يتجاوب معه لماذا
استطيع ان يقول ذلك صدقني لا احد في روسيا
سعيد لكون روسيا
ينبغي ان تقصف المنشات التحتيه بعد الهجوم
على همم الجسر في جزيره القرم
انت وده عيده
وكان الهدف هو قطع القلم عن روسيا وكان
على روسيا ان ترد وذلك محاوله
وفسره لي شولسه لكن بتبيعه الحال لن يكون
هناك تفهم
في الصحافه منذ 30 عاما وطريق الى كل هذه
المشاكل والحرب هو رفض الغرب تفهم اي نوع
او اي موقف من المنافس سواء كانت روسيا او
العراق او سوريا الغربي يعتقد من انه يعرف
اكثر من غيره واا
ادلاتنا وتفسيراتنا لا تاخذ وبعدين
الاعتبار
ويقول انها ليست صادقه بانها تعارض ااا
الغرب
لسوء الحظ لا اتوقعوا وقفا لاطلاق النار
ولا تحسنا في العلاقات بين روسيا وحلف
الناتو في اي وقت قريب وهذا
ليست هي حرب بين روسيا
والفنيته لنواجه الامر قبل يومين روسيا
قامت بشحنه صواريخ الجديده لاوكرانيا
وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لبريطانيا ويبدو من
المسيري للسخريه ان الرئيس الفرنسي قال
انه يريد ان يتصل لحد الان لم نسمع بشيء
من ذلك ولا اعتقد ان الاتصال سيكون مفيدا
لان ماكرون اتصل بهاتفين عده مرات ولكنه
حتى يعود للسيد بروك ليس لان فتقوله وما
تقوله موسكو وهنا اسد سيد بروكنر في في
برلين يوحي وكان الغرب
يسعى للتسويه والرئيس بوتن يومانع وكانه
يريد ان يفرض على الغرب ما يريده بالاكراه
الذين
اوصفوا بينهم لا يفهمون شيئا لانني لا
افهم
همم اكبر بلد في العالم يحتل ويخزوا بردا
جارا له هذا ليس منطقيا وغير مفهوم ولا
قتله الابرياء وانتهاك القانون الدولي اذا
لا ارى ما هي ما هو المخزن همم يهدد ابدا
روسيا ولم يقوم بغزو بلد والعكس هو ما حدث
همم
حلف الناتو يزيد يوسع همم اعضاء عدد
اعضائه
والغرب موحد ويفرد عقوباتنا على روسيا
ومستعد لدفع الثمن لذلك اذا هذا لا معنى
له ولا نفهم ما هي اهداف الحرب
واذا وصف بانه همم نزاع بين روسيا وحرف
الناتو فهذه وجهه نظر روسيا ولا يتقاسمها
معه سائر العالم وهناك ايضا تصريحات
للرئيس بوتن السيد بابيتش في في موسكو
عندما يسر الرئيس بوتن على مواصله العمليه
العسكريه كما تسمى ويقول بان ضرب البنيه
التحتيه في اوكرانيا ضروري ولا مفر منه
ماذا ترك لاي تسوييه
الحلو بسيطه جدا النظام في اوكرانيا ينبغي
ان يتغير لان ربما
زميلي في
برلين حتى سوبر شاينكو قبل ذلك
الرئيس السابق لاوكرانيا قال اننا سوف
نحصل على صواريخ يمكنها ان تضرب موسكو
وهذا سهل على اوكرانيا ان تفعله لان
المسافه بين اوكرانيا وهمم موسكو وهي عده
مئات من الاميال قريبه جدا اذا
كان همم في برلين لا يفهم ذلك يذكره بانه
في عام 89 كانت المانيا
الشرقيه
وانظروا ما حدث الى الفنيته من الذي يتوسع
ومع كل تنازل لروسيا
يزدادوا طلباته حلفنيته واصبحت عدائيه
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك السيد بابيتش من موسكو
معذره على المقاطعه شكرا لك السيد بروكنر
من برلين
[موسيقى]
هلا وزير الخارجيه في تركيا مولود شوشه
اوغلو ان بلاده تاثرت بالارهاب جراء ما
يحدث في سوريا مشيرا الى عدم وجود فرق بين
حزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات الشعب
معتبرا الاثنين كيانين ارهابيين بدوره دعا
وزير الدفاع
حلفاء بلاده الى قطع علاقاتها ودعمها عن
وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه وكانت الولايات
المتحده قد ابلغت تركيا بمعرضتها الشديده
لشاني انقره هجوم البريا على وحدات الشعب
في شمالي سوريا
تبدو تركيا اكثر اسرارا على المضي قدما في
عملياتها العسكريه في الشمال السوري ولكن
دون الافصاح عن ايه التفاصيل
مره اخرى جددت انقر الجمعه استمرار
معركتها ضد منتصفهم بارهابي واحداث حمايه
الشعب الكرديه شمال سوريا ولا ترافق بينها
وبين حزب العمال الكردستاني وتقول انها
كانت ارهابيه تشكل تهديدا مباشره لتركيا
وعلى لسان وزير الخارجيه مولود كاهوس
اوغلو كانت اخر التصريحات على مصنع من
الحضور في منتدى الحوار المتوسطي المنعقد
في روما تركيا تاثرت كثيرا بما يحدث في
سوريا لكن اكبر تهديدا هو الارهاب ولا فرق
بين حزب العمال الكردستاني او وحدات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه نحن نعرف من يقود جميع هذه
التنظيمات وهي كيانات ارهابيه تشكل تهديدا
مباشره لتركيا
في هذه الاثناء يتصاعد التوجس والخوف على
صعد مختلفه منذ اعلان الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان اخيرا عزمي بلاده علشان هجوم بري
ضد وحدات الشعب الكرديه في شمال سوريا
عندما يحين الوقت
وتعتقد الولايات المتحده وحلفائها ان مثل
ذلك الهجوم من شانه ان يعرض للخطر انجازات
حرب التحالف الدولي ضد تنظيم الدوله وكان
البنتاجون قد اعلنها ان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لغايه اوستن ابلغ نظيره التركي
خلوصي اكار بمعارضه واشنطن الشديده لاي
عمليه عسكريه في شمال تركيا لكن اكاري
يقول ان القوات التركيه ستقوم بواجبها
تجاه بلادها في المكان المطلوب عندما يحين
اوان ذلك المعروف ان التحالف الدولي يعتبر
ما يعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ووحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه حليفا في حربه ضد
تنظيم الدوله ويستعرف حاليا دورياته
المعتاده في مناطق سيطرتهم التي خلصها بعد
الضربات الجويه التركيه الاخيره
وبينما تطلب واشنطن من انقره اعاده
التقييم مجمل لعمليه العسكريه في الشمال
السوري فان تركيا تطالب بقطع الدعم عن
منتصفهم بالارهابيين هناك وتشدد على كونها
وقواتها المسلحه الداعم الحقيقيه للتحالف
في مواجهه مجمل الارهاب في تلك المنطقه
تتمتعه ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
بدعم امريكيه حيث يجمعهما حلف لمكافحه
الارهاب في سوريا منذ عام 2014
وتبحث هذه القوات عن الحفاظ على
استقلاليتها في اداره المناطق سيطرتها في
الشمال السوري لذلك تعول على الدور الغربي
في منعه وقوع عمليه عسكريه بريه من جانبيه
تركيا
ارتبطت مصالح وما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مع مصالح الولايات المتحده
ومن وراءها دول الغرب عندما شن الغرب حمله
عسكريه على تنظيم الدوله في معركه عين
العرب كوباني الشماليه سوريه في سبتمبر
عام 2014
تاسست بمسمى قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه عام
2015 كانت تحالفا لمقاتلين من مختلف
الاعراق لكن وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
كانت حجره الاساسي
وبريطانيا دعما بقوته الخاصه لمسانده
عمليات هذه المجموعه على الارض
لاحقا استمر الدعم الامريكي لما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه فيما اعتبره
الحالي مكافحه للارهاب في مناطق اخرى من
سوريا دير الزور والحسكه وجزء من هذه
الحمله اعتقلت ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه الاف من مقاتلي تنظيم الدوله
من الاجانب وعائلاتهم ومنهم من قدموا من
دول الاوروبيه
احتدم اثر ذلك جدلا كبير بشان مصيره هؤلاء
المعتقلين فقد رفض الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
عوده مقاتلي تنظيم الدوله الى بلدانهم
الاوروبيه فاقترحت ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تاسيس محكمه دوليه في سوريا
وتقديمهم اليها
ما تبحث عنهما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه هو اعتراف دولي بدورها يعزز
ادارتها الذاتيه للمنطقه التي تسيطر عليها
في شمال شرق سوريا ولا يتحقق لها ذلك حتى
الان في الاتحاد الاوروبي والامم المتحده
لا يواجهان دعوه للذراع السياسي لما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه من اجل المشاركه
في اي محادثات سياسيه بشان الازمه السوريه
ولا يعترفان الا بالمعارضه السوريه التي
تتخذ مقر لها في اسطنبول
اوكي عمليه عسكريه بليه جديده في الشمال
السوري تعول ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه على الحليف الامريكي الذي
يبقى الراعي الرسمي لها خارجيا لكنها
تحتفظ ايضا بقنوات تواصل مع روسيا
فاولويتها دائما هي ان تحتفظ بادارتها
المستقله للمناطق التي تسيطر عليها ولا
تضطر للتنازل عنها لا للنظام السوري والذي
تركيا في حال وقوع العمليه البريه
العسكريه
[موسيقى]
الباحثين في شؤون الشرق الادنى بعد واشنطن
والمختصار السوري اهلا بضيفين نبدا من
واشنطن وسيد تابلت واضح ان انكر تصر على
قطع واشنطن لعلاقاتها مع وحدات حمايه
الشعب هل يمكن ان تقدم واشنطن على خطوه
كهذه
اعتقد اعتقد سوف تستمر في علاقاتها مع
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ضد تنظيم الدوله
ولكن في الوقت نفسه
لكنها لن تقبل او ترفض ان يكون هناك حرب
بين الطرفين ولكن كيف يمكن لها ان تواصل
هذا التوفيق بين علاقتين لا تستقيمان مع
بعض
بيكاز تركي لان تركيا
والقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اييه يمكن هما
عدوان ولكن اقوال سوريا ديمقراطيه شريك
لامريكا في
التصدي لتنظيم الدوله وتركيا تود ان تكون
في ذلك الجزء من سوريا
يكون لها قدره على التصدي
وغيرها من
المعارضه اذا الوضع غريب ولكنه ممكن
من اوجه الغراب هنا اسال سيد الانتقام في
موسكو ان موسكو واشنطن تقريبا تشتري كان
في نفس همم الموقف من
قوات حمايه الشعب
كيف نفسر ذلك
يعني ولكن روسيا طبعا تكتيكيا تستفيد من
هذه العمليه العسكريه التركيه حاليا بسبب
ان نحن ندرك تماما نعم يوجد هناك تواصل
بين روسيا وقوات سوريا
في سوريا ولكن حقيقه الامر هي ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تستعمل الاكراد فقط
اداه اداه مزعج لكل من سوريا وروسيا
وتركيا امريكا
وسوريا
فلذلك يعني تكتكيا من روسيا تستفيد كما
يقول تستراتيجيا لا بسبب ان همم يمكن من
الصحيح ان تدخل تركيا الى سوريا ومن همم
تخرج منها همم ولكن ولكن انا اعتقد ان في
ناس ما بتعرف روسي كثير الجهود في السابق
لاقامه الحوار بين قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
هذا الكيان الفيدرالي من جهه مع سلطات
السوريه من جهه الاخرى ولكنني جديد اقول
واضح تمام ان امريكا تشغل تحركات
الانفصاليه فلذلك هذا الحوارات هذه
الجولات للحوار قد فشلت همم للاسف الشديد
على هناك حاجه لمزيد من الضغوطات على كل
من واشنطلون خلفيه في صفوف في قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه هناك ايضا نقطه اخرى مهمه
سيده
هو ان واشنطن تعتبر حزب العمال الكردستاني
تنظيما ارهابيا في حين لا ترى نفس الشيء
بالنسبه لقوات حمايه الشعب والكل يعلم
بانها هي الامتداد السوري
لحزب العمال الكردستاني
عندما
سوريا الديمقراطيه هي مجموعه لمحاربه
تنظيم الدوله
وخاصه في التحكم في غيرها من القوات مثل
واي بي جي
وهي ليس وهي
وهذا ما هو مفهوم لكن من موقف واشنطن انها
تدعم هذه القوات قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
فقط
الى هذه المساله لان انقر تعتبر بانه لا
يمكن محاربته تنظيم الدوله وهو تنظيم
ارهابي عبر تنظيم ارهابي اخر كيف تعالج
موسكو هذه الاشكاليه لدى الجانب التركي
روسيا اولا
انطلاق بان قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه هي
منظمه الارهابيه ولكن في نفس الوقت من غير
التعبير ان يوجد او توجد هناك منظمه مسلح
او الكيان المسلح همم
خارج يعني سياده الدوله السوريه خارج
الجيش السوري الرسمي فلذلك الموقف الروسي
بسيط هناك حاجه لمصالحه ما بين همم يعني
هذا الكيان اللي في دلالي
سوري
اكثر من جوله جوله الحوار بين سوريا
الديمقراطيه همم ولكن حتى كانت هناك
محاولات لمنع
العسكريه مثلا
الزيتون كان هناك محاولات الروسيه الروسيه
لاجل ادخال الجيش السوري الى عفرين ولكن
نحن نعلم الاكراد في نهايه المطاف رفض مثل
هذه المقترحات ونحن نعلم كيف انتهت الامور
في نهايه المط نفس الشيء حدث مع ان النبي
عليه الصلاه والسلام نفس الشيء يحدث حاليا
فلذلك من جديد يقول الطريقه الوحي نعم نعم
تفضل الطريق الوحيد اكمل اكمل الفكره تفضل
الطريقه الوحيده هي المصالح بين دمشق
والاكراد لانهاء الازمه السوريه شكرا
[موسيقى]
العاصمه الافغانيه وافاد المصدر بان
اشتباكا بالاسلحه دار بعد ذلك بين القوات
الامنيه وعدد من المهاجمين
بالطابق الثامن مبنا يطل على السفاره
الباكستانيه كما افاده ذاته المصدر ان
القوات الامنيه تواصل تنفيذ عمليه تمشيطيه
للمبنى وانه تم اعتقاله مهاجما واحدا حتى
الان
وقدنا رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني ما وصفه
بمحاوله اغتيال التي استهدفت رئيس البعثه
الدبلوماسيه الباكستانيه في كابول
الافغانيه ان الحكومه لن تسمح لاي جهه
بمحاوله المساسي بامن البعثات الدبلوماسيه
في كابول كما كانت بعثه الامم المتحده في
افغانستان الهجومه قائله ان السفارات
محميه بموجب القانون الدولي
ومتابعه لهذا الموضوع معنا من كابل نصرت
بل المحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك هل اتضحت
اكثر خلفيات هذا الهجوم
ثانكيو
حاجه الان نحن نتابع الوضع لهذا الحادث
والسبب وراءه
لرئيس البعثه الدبلوماسيه
لسفاره الباكستان غير معروف ولا نعرف
المسؤول عنه ايضا
هناك حديث عن علاقات متميزه تربط بين
باكستان وطالبان تاريخيا حتى هل يمكن هذا
ان يكون هذا الهجوم نوعا من محاوله دق
اسفين بين الطرفين
اه توكلير ده ايش هو
بدعه نقاط
حركه طالبان لها على علاقات وثيقه
بالحكومه الباكستانيه في 20 سنه الاخيره
وحتى قبل ذلك وفي الحرب التي قاموا بها ضد
الولايات المتحده وقوه حلف الناتو الحكومه
الباكستانيه كانت داعمه
لاماره باكستان ومجموعه
سيسكو
وسقوط النظام توقعات الحكومه الباكستانيه
كانت اعلى بكثير مما يمكن توقعه من حكومه
طالبان
ومن انها لا تستجيب
لمستوى توقعات باكستان في الشهور الاخيره
التي شاهدنا فيها توترن بين اماره
افغانستان اسلاميه والحكومه الباكستانيه
في مجالات عديده في سنه الحدود او المسائل
الاقتصاديه او ايضا السجن العديد من
الافغاني في باكستان ومشاك مشاكل للهجره
وكل هذه المسائل المجتمعه تجعلنا نرى انه
ليس هناك على قات موثوقه وجيده بين
الطرفين بالاضافه الى ذلك الى مسائل حيويه
اخرى اثرت في العلاقات بين هذين الطرفين
وهي مساله تحريك باكستاني
وحركه تيتي تي في ومن الجانب الباكستاني
يتوقع من طالبان ان
تسحبهم نحو
المفاوضات للاتفاق على وقف طويل لاتلاق
النار السياسي
لقد شهدت العلاقات بين باكستان وحكومه
الطالبان توترا متزايدا خلال هذه السنه
وسط تبادل للالتهابات بشان هجمات على
الحدود وياتي هذا التوتر وعكس ما كان
متوقعا نظرا للعلاقات الجيده التي كانت
تربط الطرفين في السابق
عندما وصل الطالبان الى السلطه في
افغانستان اغسطس العام الماضي كانت توقع
السائد في اسلام اباد ان ذلك سيخدم
المصالح الباكستانيه لوجود علاقه قديمه
بين الطرفين لكن خلافاتهم ظهرت بسرعه لان
كل طرف لم يحصل على ما كان يتوقعه من
الاخر لم تعترف باكستان بحكومه طالبان وان
دعت المجتمع الدولي الى التعامل معها قال
وزير خارج الباكستانيه ان اسلام اباد لم
تعترف بحكومه طالبان دون اجماع عند دولي
مشيرا الى ان الصبر المجتمع الدولي مع
طالبان
في المقابل تقول باكستان ان طالبان لم
تمنع الهجمات عليها من داخل الاراضي
الافغانيه وتتهمها بتوفير ملاذات امنه
لمجموعات ارهابيه اهمها طالبان باكستان
وحسب مصادر باكستانيه فان الهجمات عبر
الحدود زادت بنسبه 56 في المئه منذ وصول
طالبان الى السلطه حكومه طالبان من جهتها
تشتكي من غارات جويه يشنها الجيش
الباكستاني داخل افغانستان منها واحده في
ابريل الماضي قال الطالبان انها قتلت 50
شخصا
وتابعت بلغه لا تخلو من تهديد ان هذه
الغاره ستكون لها عواقب يبدو من تصرفات
طالبان انها تحاول اظهار انديه في تعاملها
مع باكستان في محور الصوره التي بعض بانها
تابعه لها وتدخل دعوات طالبان المتكرره
لتطوير العلاقات مع الهند غريب باكستان
التاريخيه في اطار سياسه اثبات الذات ولو
من خلال الضغط على من ظ يعتبروا اقرب حليف
[موسيقى]
بدات في العاصمه الايطاليه روما النسخه
الثامنه من منتدى حوارات المتوسط التي
تنظمها الخارجيه الايطاليه سنويا لدول حوض
البحر الابيض المتوسط تعقد الاجتماعات على
مدار يومين في شكل جلسات نقاشيه تتناول
هذا العام قضايا الطاقه وتاثيرات حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا على دول المنطقه اضافه
الى جلسات خاصه مع وزراء خارجيه عدد من
الدول العربيه
لبنان هو احد البلدان الحاضره بقوه في
المنتدى هذا العام هذا الحضور تفرضه
الجغرافيا والخصوصيه في ظل الاستحقاقات
التي يعيشها البلد وابرز هذه الاستحقاقات
الشهور الرئاسي وهو امر تعيش البلاد للمره
السادسه في تاريخها الحديث لكنه يختلف هذه
المره عن السابقين بانه يحدث في ظل حكومه
مستقيله حكما بعد الانتخابات البرلمانيه
التي اجريت في ماي واي تحدي اخر يتمثلوا
في اقرار الاصلاحات التي طلبها صندوق
النقد الدولي واهممها اعاده هيكله القطاع
المصري فيه واقرار مشروع قانون كافه
الكنترول او نظام ضبط راس المال الذي يقيد
عمليات السحب وتحويل العملات الاجنبيه من
المصاري كذلك يطالب مجلس الامن لبنان
بالالتزام حقيقي لتنفيذ القرارات الدوليه
ومنها القرار
1701 القاضي الوقفي كل العمليات القتاليه
مع اسرائيل وبسطى سياده الدوله على جميع
الاراضي من جنوب نهر الليطاني وصولا الى
الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه بمؤازره
قوات اليونيفيل الدوليه ملف اللاجئين
السوريين هو الاخر يشكل ورقه ضغط على
لبنان الذي يفتقده القدره الماليه
والخدميه والسياسيه على تحمل تداعياته حيث
يستضيف لبنان اكبر عدد من اللاجئين في
العالم مقارنه بعدد السكان
المناسقه الخاصه للامم المتحده في لبنان
اكدت في شهر مارس الماضي اكدت على الضروره
الملححه لتنفيذ اصلاحات الملموسه في لبنان
مشيره بقلقا الى استمرار التدهور
الاجتماعي والاقتصادي ومعاناه الشعب
اللبناني وتاكل القطاع العام
كما حظرت فرنتسكا في شهر يوليو تموز من ان
لبنان يقف على مفترق طرق بين النهوض
ولانهيار مشدده
في الحقيقه على قدره واستعداد قاده البلاد
لتطبيق حلول مستداما
وقبل بضع في ايام عادت لتؤكد المنسق
الامميه مره اخرى على وجوب ان يعطي قاده
لبنان الاولويه للمصلحه الوطنيه مشيره الى
الحاجه الى ان تعمل مؤسسات الدوله بكامل
الفعاليه وان تكون قادره على تنفيذ
الاصلاحات العاجله
قبل الحصاد كنت اجريت مقابله مع منسقه
الامم المتحده الخاصه بلبنان وسالتها اولا
ان كان للامم المتحده اي تصورا بشان حل
المشاكل السياسيه والاقتصاديه للبنان
[موسيقى]
اسمحوا لي ان ابدا بفكره بسيطه وهي ان
لبنان لديه موارد بشريه كامله كثيره
والشعب لديه مهارات كبيره ويستطيع ان يبني
مستقبل البلاد الى املوا ان يتخذوا
القرارات المناسبه في المستقبل ونحن في
الامم المتحده طبعا موجودونا على الارض
فهناك نحو ست و20 وكاله تابعه للامم
المتحده وقوات حفظ السلام اليونيفيل ما هو
مطلوب اليوم حسب رايي هو تنفيذ وتطبيق
الاصلاحات الضروريه واستئناف المفاوضات مع
صندوق النقد الدولي نحتاج كذلك ان يكون
لبنان مستقرا ويعمل كدوله فيها مؤسسات
فاعله وجيده وهنا سيكون انتخاب رئيس جديد
وتشكيل حكومه كامله الصلاحيه امرا مهما
جدا لكي تستطيع كل مؤسسات الدوله ان تعمل
معا من اجل المستقبل وبرؤيه واضحه للبنان
كذلك يجب ان اقول انه ينبغي ان يكون هناك
تعاون وثيق بين البرلمان والحكومه لوضع
قوانين ملموسه وتشريعات جديده والامم
المتحده مستعده لتقديم يد المساعده نحن
مثلا نتواصل بشكل كبير مع البرلمان ونواصل
الدعم عمله ومستعدون لتقديم اراء مبتكره
وجديده خاصه العام المقبل وبقدر ما يتعلق
الامر بالمساعدات الانسانيه سنبدا برنامج
جديد في السنه القادمه
وسننشئ اطار عمل لتنميه المستدامه جديده
من اجل لبنان
في لبنان الان لابد ان تبدا من انتخاب
رئيس جديد للبلاد هناك مازق على هذا
الصعيد هل هناك اي دور او ضغوط او مساعي
للامم المتحده في اتجاه تسريع انتخاب رئيس
جديد للبلاد
هو ان اقدم خدماتي بشكل جيد الامم المتحده
معروفه بحياتها وبالتالي نحن لا نناقش
اسماء المرشحين لكننا اصدقاء لبنان نحاول
فقط ان نشجع العمليه الديمقراطيه لان
انتخاب الرئيس ممارسه الديمقراطيه وانا
اقوم بذلك عن طريق الاتصال الوثيق مع جميع
اصحاب العلاقه في لبنان وكذلك احاول ان
اوفر بيئه جيده من الدعم من المنطقه من
خلال عرض خبراتي واجراء اتصالات مع الدول
العربيه وفي المنطقه يجب ان اذكر ايضا
حقيقه ان المجتمع الدوليه متحد الى حد
كبير لاننا نود ان نرى لبنان مزدهرا انا
وزملائي في الامم المتحده عندما نقدم
رسائله واضحه فاننا نتكلم لغه نفسها
نشجع رؤيه جيده لمستقبل لبنان
الاقتصاديه المستفحله المستفحله في لبنان
يبدو المجتمع الدولي وكانه ترك لبنان
يواجه مصيره
صندوق النقد الدولي ما زال مترددا في
موضوع التقديم المساعده وكذلك دول الجوار
والدول الغربيه في هذه الحاله ما العمل
[موسيقى]
طبعا عندما نتحدث عن العقبات لابد ان نسال
اصدقاءنا اللبنانيين فهم يعرفون بشكل افضل
ما هي العقبه التي يواجهونها من اجل اجراء
اصلاحات لكن لبنان وقع سنه الماضيه
اتفاقيه مع صندوق النقد الدولي بشروط
واضحه ومؤكده وقد بداوا فعلا بتبني بعض
القوانين على سبيل المثال قانون السريه
المصرفيه وشروط اخرى يفردها صندوق النقد
الدولي رغم ذلك هناك بعض القضايا العالقه
كمساله اصلاح النظام المصرفي واصدار قانون
بشان السيطره على رؤوس الاموال هناك
معايير يستخدمها صندوق النقد الدولي وهذه
تعد بدايه وبعد الاستجابه لكل الشروط نامل
في يوم ما ان لبنان اتفاقا كاملا مع صندوق
النقد الدولي وهذا سيمهد الطريق لمزيد من
التمويل من جانب الصندوق ومن دول المنطقه
ايضا الحكم الرشيد هو امر مطلوب الى حد
كبير لانه اذا تحققت هذه الانجازات في
لبنان من قبل جميع الاطراف وعلى كل
المستويات سوف يستطيع لبنان ان يستعيد
الثقه من جديد وهذا امر ضروري جدا لكي
يتحمس الشعب من جديد لاجل بلاده
رجاله ان توزي
شكرا جزيلا لك يا سيدنا
المنسق الخاصه للامم المتحده في لبنان كنت
معنا من روما شكرا جزيلا
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا
موعدنا مع مزز لاهم واخر الانباء قبل
الانتقال الى الجوله الرياضيه يوميات
المونديال في مشهد صادما وثقته الكاميرات
لعمليه اعدام الميزانيه نشر ناشطون صورا
تظهروا قتل شاب فلسطيني برصاص الاحتلال في
حواره نابلس وحاول فلسطينيين تخليص الشاب
من قبضه الجندي الذي اطبق الخناقه عليه
وصحبه الى مكان اخر واطلق النار عليه وقال
شهود عيان ان القوات الاحتلال منع التواقم
الاسعاف من الوصول الى الشاب بعد اصابته
وقد طالبه الرئاسه الفلسطينيه بحمايه
دوليه مما وصفته بجرائم منهجه للحكومات
الاسرائيليه فيما قال الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
تصاعد العنف الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه
والقدس المحتله يثير قلقا متزايده كما
وصفت الفصائل الفلسطينيه ما جرى بانه
جريمه
طلب المستشار الالماني الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين باتاحته فرصه للحل
الدبلوماسيه عبر سحب قوته من اوكرانيا من
جهه قال الكريملين ان اشتراطا انسحاب
الروسي من اوكرانيا غير ممكن مشددا ان
العمليه العسكريه ستتواصل في الاثناء
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الى سرعه
البحث عن ارضيه تفاوض مشتركه
اورده وكاله رويترز ان ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه اعلنت تعليق التنسيق
والعمليات المشتركه مع التحالف الدولي
بقياده الولايات المتحده بعد القصف التركي
ياتي ذلك بعد يومين من اعلان فانت تكون
تقديس دورياته في المنطقه
هذا وقد دعوى وزير الدفاع التركيه خلص يا
اكار حلفاء بلاده الى قطع علاقاتها ودعمها
عن وحدات حمايه الشعب التي وصفها
بالارهابيه
نقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصدر الامني ان
مسلحين اطلق النار على مقر السفاره
الباكستانيه وسط العاصمه الافغانيه وافاد
المصدر ان اشتباكن بالاسلحه دار بعد ذلك
بين القوات الامنيه وعدد من المهاجمين في
مبنا يطل على السفر
نهايه الحصاد في امان الله
[موسيقى]